the history of studying heavenly bodies
accounts for centuries some space
objects are so remote that only the use
of powerful telescopes makes it possible
to observe them
while others are so large and luminous
that we are sometimes able to see them
with the naked eye
jupiter the largest planet in the solar
system
falls into the latter group people have
been aware of the existence of this gas
giant since time a memorial
and starting with the 1970s spacecraft
have been used for its exploration
all in all nine spacecraft have visited
the planet's environs in the past
50 years and currently there is one
interplanetary space probe in the
giant's orbit
juno what data has it already received
about this planet
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the juno mission started in june 2005
when the probe was at the stage of
preliminary design
lockheed martin space systems was in
charge of constructing the space probe
under the supervision of nasa's jet
propulsion laboratory
juno was launched on august 5th 2011
atop the atlas v rocket and four years
and 11 months later
the probe locked into jupiter's orbit
on this arduous journey juno has had to
face a number of difficulties
on august the 30th 2012 when the probe
was already 483 million kilometers away
from the earth
the flight's trajectory was adjusted for
the first time
as a result the probe's speed boosted by
388 meters per second
with a spacecraft's trajectory
redirected back to the earth
thanks to this juno was ready for a
gravity boost maneuver near the earth
which was planned for october the 9th
2013.
the maneuver having been performed the
probe's speed
tripled to 40 000 kilometers per hour
on approaching our planet juno took
pictures of the south american coast
and the atlantic jupiter was the next
checkpoint on the probe's
travel its orbit was reached on july the
5th
2016 after a distance of 2.8 billion
kilometers had been covered
this made juno the second spacecraft to
a vented jupiter's orbit
[Music]
the initial objectives of the mission
involved exploring jupiter's
gravitational and magnetic fields
as well as ascertaining the hypothesis
as to the existence of a solid core in
the planet's center
in addition the probe has to explore the
planet's atmosphere
and determine the ratio of water and
ammonia
as well as map its winds which are able
to reach the speed of up to 618
kilometers per hour
juno will also continue exploring the
areas of jupiter's south and north poles
a task started by pioneer 11 and cassini
to reach these girls successfully the
probe is powered by solar panels
which are the largest among all other
panels used on interplanetary space
probes
using infrared and microwave instruments
juno is able to gauge the thermal
radiation emanating from the depths of
the planet
these observations will complement the
previous explorations
by assessing the amount of water and
consequently
oxygen these data will provide better
insight into jupiter's origins
and therefore those of the entire solar
system as well
in addition to that juno will also
investigate the convection processes
that drive general circulation in the
planet's atmosphere
to emphasize the historic significance
of the mission juno's creators placed
several symbolic items on board
those are a plaque depicting galileo
galilei and three
aluminium lego minifigures representing
galileo himself
the roman god jupiter and his wife juno
the very first snapshots beamed back by
the probe
depicted jupiter in a series of color
images
which were later made into a short video
in this video we can observe a unique
site where jupiter looks like a crescent
seen from the earth however only the
whole of this planet is visible to us
on august 27 2016
juno flew by jupiter's cloud zone at a
distance of 4
000 kilometers thereby enabling
scientists to have a better view of its
north and south poles
as a rule we perceive this planet to be
striped
however it's a different site at its
poles it happens because time zones
there are non-existent
and great quantities of rain merge into
large scale spiraling vortices
that roam the polar atmosphere for an
indefinite time
this poses a stark contrast with let's
say saturn
where we can see rather well-defined
hexagonal clouds at its poles
here are the spiral vortices peculiar to
jupiter's pearls
having studied the planet in the
infrared range
scientists succeeded in discovering warm
zones inside the planet
and mapping out the planet's clouds with
higher precision
here is a computer model that
demonstrates the infrared scanning
results
juno even managed to capture the aurora
on jupiter
using its microwave radio meter which
detected this phenomenon
this is the view of northern lights at
jupiter's south pole
while carrying out the analysis the
probe was able to determine that the
stratified structure of jupiter's
atmosphere
perseveres down to its lowest layers
where it starts to gradually change
here is jupiter's atmosphere
if the mission ends successfully the
scope of human knowledge will certainly
be enhanced with a new array of valuable
data
about this mammoth planet
jupiter is highly notable for its famous
great red spot
juno captured its detailed image as well
on july the 10th
2017. here is a snapshot of jupiter with
a great red spot
the north is on the right the south is
on the left the 10th of july 2017.
thanks to juno's investigation of this
mysterious phenomenon
it transpired that the giant red vortex
penetrates the planet's atmosphere 320
kilometers deep
and whirls anticlockwise at the speed of
over 500 kilometers per hour
very soon scientists concluded that
jovian hurricane winds are caused by
temperature difference
just like on our earth juno found out
that the roots of the great red spot are
tucked in
50 or 100 times the depth of our oceans
and their base is warmer than their top
the image depicts data from six
channels of juno's microwave radiometer
spot measures are staggering sixteen
thousand kilometers in width
and forty thousand kilometers in length
that is its one point three diameters of
our earth juno's images
also allowed scientists to conclude that
jupiter's north pole
is the center of a powerful cyclone with
eight smaller cyclones densely and quite
symmetrically arranged around it
they range from four thousand to four
and a half thousand kilometers in
diameter
the wind speed in these vortices reaches
350 kilometers per hour
here are the atmospheric vortices and
north moderate area on jupiter
the snapshot was taken on may the 23rd
2018 from the distance of 7
900 kilometers from the planet's cloud
layer
a similar pattern of enormous
atmospheric vortices was found in the
southern area as well
however in contrast there are five of
them there
not eight and they are larger with the
diameters ranging from five and a half
thousand
to seven thousand kilometers scientists
have been closely observing them for two
years by now
in their attempt to determine how stable
they are and whether they change as time
goes by
the luminous areas of the clouds have
the temperature of minus 13 degrees
centigrade and the darkest ones minus
188 degrees
this film was made out of a series of
images beamed back by the spacecraft on
october the 29th
2018.
in it we can see juno approaching
jupiter's santa
in the middle of september 2019 the juno
probe approached jupiter for the 22nd
time
and here is one of its images
transmitted to us
juno's grand finale is scheduled for
when it is going to be deorbited and go
on to plunge itself into jupiter's
atmosphere
destined to burn up this decision was
made
so as to avoid the probe's collision
with a galilean satellite
where life is potentially sustainable
after this scientists will proceed to
process all the data
gathered by juno this analysis is going
to take
several years it is too early to talk
about the results of this legendary
mission
as it is highly likely that so far juno
hasn't yet made its major discoveries
there still remain 15 orbits around
jupiter
to be completed we appreciate our
audience that is you dear friends
that's why we try to bring under
scrutiny the most exciting and bizarre
things to be found in this diverse
and fascinating world so grab this mouse
and hit the like button
under the video it is your likes and
comments that motivate me to explore new
horizons
these can only be reached with your
support and subscription to this channel
keep in touch and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you